[Music]
and get him grandpa
submitted by a diarrhea touch at an 83
year old grandfather pushed a suspected
burglar off his roof to end a police
standoff oh this was a gangster it makes
me wonder what he was like when he was
younger
oh yeah this is him calm down yeah holy
[ __ ]
let me never would have snapped that
most negatives believe me or or it's
when you get older you get cranky or
maybe it's developed as age come on get
off my roof ever what same in Clint
Eastwood's Reno get off mine oh [ __ ] you
knew that before she even [ __ ] wait
what is that what is that what is it
it's one of the worst best movies ever
yes the Asian the kid actor fine annoyed
the [ __ ] out of that they were trying
they're all non-actors right no they're
not they're just how a real mom how they
can't sit for this because they need
among actors and they went to that cuz
in Minnesota or oh yeah yeah yeah
there's a huge community of Hmong people
there and there was not one good long
after no none of them were even actors
yeah they wanted to be on feds not one
good one person egg someone do it out no
no I mean for whatever he did it was
very authentic so you know there's no
you know there's no what it is how many
times did shrimp dicks movie oh yeah duh
it's Hmong food that's what she said
there's like god you're not that great
of an actress I wish I understood Hmong
spelling like among your wishes are
[ __ ] many ways this 83 year old
grandpa uh he was so this takes place in
lap one bit oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah hmm not
crazy
where's look what does point I mean it's
like where the Krispy Kremes is over
there oh it's so sad that I know where
the Krispy Kreme is but I know one look
one day that's anyways does that mean
lap went there and there was this
suspected burglar that kept jumping
rooftops and
how close are these rooftops I know I
was thinking the same thing in
spider-man job that's pretty hard yes
well you deserve this go away that's
[ __ ] amazing kill do that community
where everything looks like the same
true oh yeah like that you be some type
of a nuisance so uh Wilfred is the
grandpa he sounds like a grandma
that's a grandpa it's so cute in the
interview too and his wife Agnes and his
daughter Gretchen so a suspect would not
come down from his roof so that's when
this grandpa went over to his neighbor's
house and said let me borrow your ladder
I'm taking this guy [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] crap
was bored as [ __ ] it how long did it
take for him to get on the roof stuff
you wouldn't have done that he's Samoan
grandma is on the roof there's a reason
Wilfred Burgesses up there trying to get
that man off his roof I didn't gave you
to pay matter what I had enough I figure
this is my house yeah oh that's a low
roof yeah yeah anything on the car so he
crushed the but they ended up arresting
him hey why his boy sounds young three
three his boy sounds really he's a spy
yeah black don't crack
that's right damn he's got some crazy
fix these tops yeah that's what cops
couldn't get the cops couldn't get him
in the cop even tweeted out something
along the lines of like they got
something we couldn't do out of shape
are these [ __ ] cops yes you [ __ ]
lazy that's not allowed to go on
rooftops
I guess not beyond their appearance you
just borrow a ladder too and then go you
might have been scared of heights that
would have been me yeah I can't do that
[ __ ] yeah I don't know I guess maybe
they can't but he ended up tweeting
you're not saying like the grandpa did
what we could
how come he gets our for attempted
murder but then like the [ __ ] little
[ __ ] gonna be like he hurt me when you
push me off I'm suing you yeah let's
California yeah is there anything about
property deals on his property though it
does not protect the grandpa at work
there's no such thing as trespassing it
doesn't shoot him yeah you can't hurt
him and he's gotta assume like roaches
like just like that yeah just have the
law were like if you shoot them in the
back you're in trouble I don't know
about that but your car is also
considered your castle too so if people
break into your car while you're inside
you could shoot them and all that stuff
but like if they're running away and you
shoot them is that okay I feel like it
is because remember that we watched that
lady that Asian lady that got home yeah
and they have the cats law and then they
were running away or someone yeah yeah
but they have the castle law so when
people were running away she shot at
them and then the - it was [ __ ] tight
pastel and then after it was done it
pots like two seconds she went one for
good measure
she was dope that was like a crazy yeah
but this is so close to our homes like
would you guys do this get on your own
roof and push the small about a gun I'll
just pointed out oh and I need something
get off and call the cops I'll not to
move I think I probably would just wait
him out and I'll just put a lot of like
broken glass all around him and I just
light it on fire good luck buddy they're
burning down your own house myself down
what are you uh what are you just target
practice with a paintball gun just to
piss them off feel bad well I should
have you [ __ ] actually [ __ ] let me
[ __ ] audience we gotta use airsoft
this morning oh yeah you're smart no
because there's paint marks and
you abused me yeah yeah but with the
airsoft gun and it's just little stings
aim for the face mm-hmm oh that was so
cool they're jumping in with the paint
yeah just fall over put meat loaf on the
roof he might run away it's got a cone
on he's scared of humans right I never
seen him get aggressive - I never seen
your aggressive metahuman I mean he did
crawl it and um daddy's firm yeah yeah
he picks and chooses I don't know well
put him on we'll see we does yeah I like
it was fine he's not the pentomino just
get that ready Oh what was this guy's
stealin oh yeah that was my question
oh they just mentioned that he's a
suspected burglar just rides bicycles
and stuff skateboard yeah yeah well
Bradley was like hours-long standoff
that's why the crime came out better
that's embarrassing man you haven't
liked your the cops and you're standing
off for hours and this 81 83 year old
man I'll do it myself for you yeah it
Robbie does show your true gusto though
when you're in those type of situations
because you know I could say as much as
I want I can't do something I actually
don't know I might just stare at him and
laugh you know I mean or I might call
the cops because in my mind I do think
I'm a hero
especially on the internet with all
those videos really everyone's a hero of
their own story yeah I would have
stopped him not even doing anything
though he's just standing on the roof so
I think my first reaction would be
grabbing my camera look at guys there's
cops here right now hey guys Joe this
guy hey why you out my roof yeah do you
want credit what's your Instagram I'll
give you a shadow but if he was on the
roof stomping around while you're trying
to take a nap yeah Bernie he's on your
room yeah and a standoff with the cops
how can we stop poppy roofs like what
yeah why didn't stay there tired
he got surrounded those eyes look
Dec Canada and it was just the grandpa
and then the grandpa like cornered him
in a weird like position well the cops
are there too and but weren't they there
for hours to like yeah yeah yes so
they're like taze them or something
paddles teacher guns you can tell yeah
yeah one of my favorite things to do was
to climb roots like in elementary school
did you guys ever go through that phase
like in what fourth grade or third grade
when you start climbing things a lot I
grew up in like the suburbs where all
the walls of everyone's house is
connected yeah just go on that wall and
I would just start like looking through
everyone's backyard and go all the way
down the street and walk block all the
back like a tightrope you're just like
walk yeah I'm just walking look okay you
got a pool
I wouldn't ladder up the roof but then I
get scared to come down is that the claw
someone help me it happened a lot too
do you get scared actually he's filming
good oh that that scene was freaking
funny because like Justin something
laughing because hey you got to climb up
the roof and then you have to bring the
ladder up I looked at that one that's it
you got one you got one I had to do like
twice but that's the most scariest thing
I had to do comes I get dizzy so I just
had to like focus as hard as possible
cuz you I have to lean over at the grab
the ladder on that's scary yeah so
that's my escape I got so freaked out
but you know you had a feel for the film
but nothing did a great job you're not
over it yet I didn't do anything no
because it's not that it's not the fear
it's the dizziness that gets me so if I
didn't get dizzy it wouldn't be as much
as a problem you know cuz that's when
you just start to keel over yeah I mean
yeah when I want to echo Mountain and I
fell over that's what I got freaked out
because I never had that dizzy spell
before it was just I'm scared but then I
went it's like burning or something
right yeah so I fell over that's what I
was like I got really traumatized we had
we have Jackie Chan now we have David so
just the ladder
believe it or not I can imagine a first
take you just like leans over all right
consuit Ian yeah Kathina you know it was
very tight I could see like how so we
didn't have obviously a big budget but
we had a crane that went all the way up
and we had a top shot on the roof and
that should frighten me cuz I just want
a large screen this shooting done with
the [ __ ] like 3040 thousand dollar
camera I see the linemen fixing the
lines yeah the wind blows and division
that little bucket and that they're just
like on the holy [ __ ] window washers
on the sky oh do you see those pictures
from like that early 1900s when they're
eating lunch on it be eating lunch on a
beam with no wires they just like taking
nap since there's no hook on them they
have a ham and cheese sandwich at a coke
yeah the beam like between their legs
yeah yeah that's crazy champagne Nath on
and one bad dreamer is [ __ ] dead I
followed that Russian do that likes to
climb Dubai buildings and he just
released a video on Instagram where he
was trying to get this motley feds where
they hang the models off the side of the
building and it was like behind the
scenes that he had the camera rolling
for video in the model she's like huh
initially that you put on a sexy face
and then [ __ ] I was [ __ ] scared for
her that [ __ ] makes my hands because
they're doing like [ __ ] somersaults
on this thin ass thing or they jump one
of them [ __ ] what is it they did that
that that kicked a kickflip on a
skateboard on the edge of a [ __ ]
80-something for building means you
should observe there has to be like a
genetic like white person gene always
white people that crashed everything and
dukey should be insane mm-hmm hope you
guys enjoyed that episode of JK news
make sure to stay connected because
we're constantly updating our social
media so follow us at JK films for
Instagram and at JK films for Twitter to
watch more videos click right over here